On top of being dragged through the family court system
for no fucking reason other than I wanted to be free.
Um, I also had my last roommate vandalize my car and destroyed it.
And then I haven't had a car since
because my insurance didn't cover the whole thing. So
thankfully,
whatever. That's a whole another fucking story.
But the point is, I'm now a single mother to four kids.
One of them is disabled. She's a fucking wish kid.
And I have no car in Colorado,
and I'm hocking shit on the TikTok shop to try to make enough money.
So since my car got broken into,
I did get cameras, but the one that we have in the front is not like
a doorbell kind of camera.
So I got this one off the TikTok shop.
If you just click on the link,
that would be super helpful too,
cause then it pushes it
and maybe somebody who wants to to buy it will buy it.
You can just watch for the free entertainment of tears on the internet.
But it also comes with the card.
Like, this is a really sweet deal.
It's a dope. This one is the wired version,
so I'm gonna have to figure out how to do that.
But the product itself is really dope.
Um,
I have to pay like $6,000.
Ugh. Whatever.
Um, it's a really cool fucking thing.
And it's linked right here.
Okay. It's packaged really well.
Um,
So, yeah,
whatever.